this is a production of cornell
university
so
uh my my last department seminar was
actually on the 19th of february i
looked it up in 2020 so i was close to
being kind of the closing act before
uh before kovid uh
shut us down and we kind of went to an
all virtual world so i'm i'm happy
that's over hopefully and i'm glad to be
back at least to some degree in front of
a live audience after two years of of
pretty much talking to my cat at home we
got a kitten at the start of the
pandemic and she's been uh pretty much
my sounding board for uh research areas
for the last two years
so my seminar today
i'm going to pick up sort of where i
left off two years ago
i'm going to include just enough review
for those of you who are who are the
more recent arrivals you've gotten here
in the last two years
so i'm going to talk about where we are
today in the research on light
to suppress plant diseases
some of you have heard
about the work on grapes and other crops
possibly on strawberries it's been in
the news lately
what you might not have seen is the
overall scope of the project
which involves test sites on diverse
crops around the us and overseas
it's a big project involving many people
my job is really to function as the kind
of project director and
public relations for uh for the group of
scientists that spread across several
institutions and countries and
corporations so a lot of the work i'm
going to be presenting today was
actually done by other people
on that research team
but as the project coordinator if you're
really interested in the peer-reviewed
papers in the area
popular articles posters
contact information for any of the
people involved
videos educational resources
visits to the various test sites around
the world across the country
training and collaborative opportunities
if you're interested in the work you
want to try it out on your particular
path of system i'm
able to provide all of that so uh so
please contact me
so
let's get started i want to try to put
this work into some kind of uh
temporal perspective i've used the slide
before it never gets old for me possibly
because the tyrannosaurus is over 201
million years old before i uh started
using it
it's around even before i arrived at
cornell
microbial pathogens have a 100 million
year head start on the tyrannosaur so
they've been attacking plants for a very
long time
uh they have a huge head start on humans
all right okay so here we go this is the
one this is the slide i wanted to get up
for about the last four minutes so
these are two adjacent greenhouses um
attached to barton lab
photographed them just after sunset now
there's substantial diversity
among lighting systems and spectral
distribution and i just wanted to
reinforce that
that just as you can see a difference in
the spectral distribution the color of
light here
fungal plant pathogens have photosensory
and regulatory systems and they
they respond differentially to different
parts of the visible spectrum now
anytime you
move a crop into an environment like
this
pottery mildews can become uh your
number one problem uh the conventional
wisdom is that this exacerbation of
powdery mildews is due to more favorable
temperatures and relative humidity in
inside of these uh controlled
environments we now know that much of
that consequent increase is really
caused by fundamental changes uh to
sunlight
that are caused uh primarily by the
exclusion of natural solar uv and by the
way we use supplemental lighting
there's nothing in the evolutionary
biology of powdery mildews or other
plant pathogens that equips them to deal
with the spectral changes caused by the
the imposition of glass or plastic
between them and the sun
or
likewise their their evolutionary
evolutionary biology is shaped by the
rising and setting of the sun not by
electric lighting that has a temporal
and spectral distribution that is um
when viewed from an evolutionary time
scale it's it's totally unfamiliar to
these pathogens
i mean we could also spend some time
discussing how to disrupt
photoregulatory systems that control
pathogen growth and sporulation
solid state leds for example allow you
to do something with light that most
pathogens have never seen before and
that's that's counter phasing or
alternating uh different wavelengths so
instead of red with blue as they would
see in natural lighting
pathogens can see red and blue
alternately or out of phase uh and with
leds you can do that thousands of times
in a single second
you're acting upon the phytochrome and
cryptochrome systems uh in opposition
rather than in synchrony
and if we did that if i covered all that
material uh we'd be here for a very long
time that's really three different
seminars so today we're going to just
talk about one of those evolutionary
traits and see how we can use it against
a pathogen and that one trait is uh is
really how they deal with ultraviolet
light
so
i mean above ground pathogens live in a
world that's bathed in sunlight now
ultraviolet light is a part of the
natural solar spectrum
and ultraviolet light causes damage to a
pathogen's dna
now despite the occurrence of that
damage
pathogens can thrive in natural solar
uv because they possess systems that can
repair that damage to their dna just
about as fast as it occurs
those dna repair
mechanisms are dependent on blue light
they're recharged by blue light they
don't operate during darkness and that
last little fact is the key to using uv
successfully to suppress a plant
pathogen now a real breakthrough
occurred about 10 years ago when a phd
student named arupoli sutherparen
on the research team in norway
discovered that applying uv light
at night was much more effective in
killing a powdery mildew on cucumber
plants
than when it was applied in daylight in
effect applying uv at night bypasses the
pathogens ability to repair the damage
to its dna that discovery allowed us to
use about 10
of the dose of uv that's required during
daylight to achieve the same degree of
kill
in a microorganism now we now know that
night time uv applications are similarly
more effective against many pathogens
and at a dose that's far below
that which causes any damage to the
plant
so
you can read all about the biochemical
and genetic aspects of this phenomenon
if you really want to in excruciating
detail there's a lot written about it
the bottom line for practical purposes
is that
for pathogens such as powdery mildews
which are in this slide
uh and many other organisms
they're simply not adapted to deal with
uv at night and that means we can kill
them with a fraction of the dose that's
required uh during daylight now our
initial trials uh targeted various
powdery mildews because they are on the
outside of the plant that makes them an
easy target
uh they're especially vulnerable to uv
but we've since found ways
to use uv against other diseases and
even arthropod pests
so i want to go back in time a bit
to the early 1990s because i think this
particular part of the work is a fitting
example of just how far we've come
uh in this research area but the
gentleman seated on this tractor is uh
named al michaloski uh he's passed away
now but he was an engineer who retired
from research and worked on industrial
photocopiers that use uv light
uh he approached bob seem and i in 1991
with this kind of crazy idea that
ultraviolet light
might actually control uh grapevine
diseases because that interested him
because in his retirement uh he had
decided to kind of kick back and slow
down relax and do something really easy
he was going to grow wine grapes in
upstate new york
this is the tractor-drawn array of
germicidal uh uvc lamps uh that came out
of that early collaboration to suppress
powdery mildew on on grapevines
the uv treatments were quite effective
uh they also made the grapes look a
little bit like
small rusted potatoes and they
defoliated the barns so
uh
well if you're gonna fail by all means
fail fast so
this was not the response we'd hoped for
and we kind of walked away from this
area of research
for several years after that and worked
on other things
so
so kind of fast forward
um
about 30 years
and we're presently on the threshold of
an entirely new approach to controlling
plant diseases and we got there because
we have a much better understanding now
of pathogen biology and pathogen ecology
and because of the pooled engineering
and physics and manufacturing expertise
of this large
diverse project team the discovery of
the enhanced efficacy of nighttime uv
was part of that
but there were a number of other
refinements as well
now strawberries are the crop in which
we worked a lot of the bugs out of the
system
um so i'll spend a little time on
strawberry before we move on to grapes
and some other crops so this picture
shows the basic design of the uv lamp
array that we designed in 2016 for the
first large scale
commercial
trials on strawberries
over each row there's a hemi cylindrical
bank of 20 uvc lamps they're backed by
polished aluminum reflectors that
densely packed array of lamps and
reflectors provides a very large number
of reflectance angles and that turns out
to be quite important
dose throughout that three-dimensional
space
under the tunnel is very uniform
irrespective of the distance of a
particular leaf or fruit
to the nearest lamp
it's mostly diffuse radiation not direct
the multiple reflectance angles also
mean there's improved exposure of the
under surfaces of many of the leaves and
fruit
this unit was operated at a commercial
strawberry farm in florida in 2017
the dose that we used was 85 joules per
square meter and the applications were
made twice a week starting about an hour
after sunset the tractor speed was just
under three miles per hour
and this is going to be a short video
clip showing what it looks like
underneath one of the units during one
of the nighttime applications you can
see the hemi cylindrical banks of uvc
lamps and the reflectors over each row
of plants
the power for the lamps was supplied by
a small generator now this was a unit
that we designed but it was entirely
built and operated by the farm crew
at the research site these are not
terribly difficult machines to build
and the treatments actually worked uh
very well
uh in fact the dose of uv that we used
provided suppression of powdery mildew
across the duration of of the entire
growing season that was substantially
better than the best fungicide
combination that we used in the trial
which was a combination of two materials
called
quintec and torino
we also confirmed that the uv treatments
didn't reduce plant size and they didn't
reduce the yield of harvested berries
important
now this is a video of what we call the
dragon 2.0
this is a tractor-drawn unit that's now
in operation at a place called fancy
farm in plant city florida
at the center of eastern strawberry
production it looks a little bit less
like a runaway tool shed
you can see how we're getting closer to
something that might resemble a
commercial production unit
after years of building these things we
have a large enough footprint in
multiple crops that we've attracted the
attention of equipment manufacturers uh
that was our intent uh
i personally and so other members of the
research team want to get out of the
business of building these things and
get stay in the business of discovery
that's that's really what we do best
we're not a manufacturing concern
we've expanded the strawberry trials in
florida and elsewhere in north america
and in europe uh some of the most
intense interest uh in the uv technology
actually comes from strawberry nursery
operations
because they're under
really tremendous pressure to reduce
fungicide use because
nursery operators need to prevent the
distribution
of plants that harbor pathogens that are
pre-selected
for high levels of fungicide resistance
so whatever fungicide you use in the
nursery it's very likely
it's going to be also used in the fruit
production field
that you can imagine the potential for
disaster if
plants that harbor a pre-selected
pathogen population are then treated
with the fungicide for which the prior
selection occurred in the nursery
and so we're collaborating with some of
the larger nursery operations on both
coasts of north america
this is the largest unit we've designed
to date uh and it's presently being used
in a place called kedi nurseries in
kentville nova scotia it has 90 uh uv
lamps arrayed in three separate eight
foot long arrays that cover three five
foot wide beds of strawberry nursery
plants it can move up to five miles per
hour it's pretty fast for a tractor that
you have to drive at night
we call this one smog after the
fire-breathing dragon and lord of the
rings
point showing this to you is that the
technology is scalable it's adaptable
and these uv arrays can be configured
for
really any number of canopy
architectures
now in addition to
the tractor-drawn units there are fully
autonomous robotic carriages that can
move these uv lamp arrays either in
field settings or inside of high tunnels
or or greenhouses
our principal collaborator in this work
has been sagar robotics it's a norwegian
company but we work with other robotics
companies as well
this image shows one of the high tunnel
trials in norway
uh the results in europe where they have
even more severe problems with fungicide
resistance and fewer fungicide options
have been pretty consistent
the uv treatments effectively suppress
powdery mildew and in most cases they
can perform as well or better
than the best available fungicides
so i think with
reference to strawberry powdery mildew
we're beyond the point where we have to
worry about whether or not the
technology is going to provide control
of strawberry powdery mildew it it
actually works quite well
the saga robot is called torvald it's an
interesting device it takes a basic lamp
array and allows us to adapt it
to any variety of fruit crops including
strawberries grapes
apples even hops
by varying the height and width
of the lamp array and the carriage the
torvald robot is fully autonomous
meaning that where it's allowed by law
it can navigate these plantings without
uh the involvement of a human operator
or monitor
these devices are presently
they're largely one-off custom built
units
they're probably within about a year of
being commercially available either as a
unit for purchase or as a leased unit
with technical support
i mean like everything else that's been
manufactured during a global pandemic
saga robotics is not unique it's
challenged by any number of choke points
in their supply and distribution chains
so this has been uh it's been a delay
but not
uh
not an insurmountable obstacle
as i mentioned a moment ago we're
kind of trying to stay in the business
of discovery not manufacturing so one of
the more recent refinements in the
technology has been the addition of uv
reflective curtains to the front and
back of the lamp race that may not sound
like much but it takes a very special
fabric it's it's not that easy to
reflect uv
in fact it's the same reflective
material that's used in navy firefighter
suits for shipboard fires
it's a bit pricey
it boosts the uv dose however by about
30 percent and it provides even better
coverage of the otherwise shaded uh
parts of the canopy under the array
that means we can
both go faster and at the same time uh
get improved coverage of the otherwise
uh shaded parts of the canopy
that 30
boost in irradiance under the array
translates directly into a 30 increase
in ground speed and a corresponding
decrease in the fixed costs as you
spread them across 30 percent more
acreage
and that's all for the price of you know
a few yards of shiny cloth
and that kind of innovation in
developing the various uh different
types of uh mobile arrays in lamps
is now occurring in several locations
both in the u.s and elsewhere where
mobile booms and tract units and these
autonomous robots are being used to move
these lamp arrays either within plant
production structures
or in field plantings for a number of
different crops
now during the late winter of 2019 to
2020 uh just about a month before
everything hit the fan with respect to
covet 19. i was in the pacific
working on design
[Music]
awesome
a year before that in 2019
whoops
get that to advance
so we had conventional uh tractor-drawn
units in new york treating grapevines
uh
with uh and as well as low trellis tops
and in 2020 we had two of the torvold
robotic units
from saga working in vineyards in the
finger lakes region we had those two
those same two robotic units in new york
again
in 2021 as well as additional units in
oregon and another one in italy
we'll have those two torvald robotic
units in california this year
and they should also be commercially
available as i said about
2023.
now showing applicability
of the uv technology across several
crops
is how we get the attention of equipment
manufacturers
it's also how we reduce the costs of
producing the units
there's another good reason to work on
several uh fronts simultaneously because
by doing so that's how we make new
discoveries in the basic biology
the epidemiology
uh which transcend
the specifics of a particular crop
or a particular pest or disease they may
have uh very broad applications
uh to many crops
these these machines and the technology
it has a certain cool factor
uh they're undeniably fun to watch at
night they're kind of pretty
but it's the research on the
epidemiology the pathogen ecology
photobiology that makes these machines
work i'm going to give you a couple of
quick examples of that
so fireblade of apple and pear is it's
one of the most destructive diseases on
tree fruit worldwide in fact it's the
principal reason why the california pear
industry is a tiny fraction of what it
was in the 1980s
firefly pretty much eliminated it
there are very few
sustainably effective antibiotics that
can be used against this bacterial
pathogen and alternatives to antibiotics
are sometimes minimally effective
there was no real reason to expect that
uv applications would be
much better than that
the bacterium like most others has a
remarkably fast reproductive rate
and we would have expected that it would
have rebounded quite quickly after a uv
exposure even if we were able uh to
reduce the bacterial populations with uv
when we tried it last spring in a
collaborative study with carrick cox's
program it actually reduced the disease
to trace levels and it performed as well
as anything else
in the trial
we don't understand yet how this is
accomplished that's going to come later
uh but it was nonetheless highly
effective
here's another example
uh from a collaborative study with sarah
pethy burge's program
the the cell walls of the fungus that
causes cercospora uh leaf spot on beets
they're heavily pigmented and melonized
now presumably that provides a robust
defense against uh natural solar uv we
were still able to suppress the disease
using weekly nighttime applications of
uv
the dose required was considerably
higher
than what we use on grapevines but it
didn't damage the beet foliage to the
point of reducing yield
and it certainly didn't damage the
foliage to the degree that sarcospora
does if it's not controlled
the discovery
here was that what we presume to be a
barrier to uv is is not really absolute
you could overcome it uh at uv doses
that are still not harmful to the crop
and that pattern
uh keeps repeating in diverse trials
where we've conducted
uh that
well
where the more we do the more we learn
you never know what you're going to see
until you look
here's another example from a
collaborative study with lance caleb
davidson david combs and katie
this experiment began in 2019
uh with
really with great pottery mildew being
the target
but we found that uv treatments were
also controlling sour rot uh and they
were controlling that to a degree that
was that was quite surprising better
than many other things that we were
using now
sour rot is a complex mess involving
bacteria and fruit feeding insects and
fungi all working together in kind of a
splendid cooperation
to rot grapes
now here again we don't understand yet
how uv is accomplishing uh this
reduction that that's going to come
later the point is it was not only very
effective but it was in many ways
unexpected
neither did we expect that uv treatments
would necessarily be effective against
the downy mildew pathogen as it
represents a comparatively uh
challenging target it's actually inside
uh the grape leaves and the fruit but
lab assays uh that were started by the
syria subcoda in our lab
showed that the pre-treatment of
grapevine leaves made them resistant to
infection for several days afterwards
now this was the first time
we'd seen disease suppression that was
caused by uv increasing the resistance
of the host to infection now it's it's
one thing to see an effect like that in
the lab it's not always something that
you can reproduce in the field and so we
we got bold and we decided to run a
field trial on chardonnay during the
2020 growing season
probably guess where this is going
had we stopped with the laboratory
studies we probably would have been a
lot happier uh because 2020 turned out
to be one of the more severe years
for downy mildew on record and none of
our uv treatments provided suppression
of the disease under vineyard conditions
katie i'm sorry for what i did to your
grapevines
still living it down uh
the uv treatments worked fine against
powdery mildew they just didn't have the
degree of efficacy needed to completely
control downy mildew as a stand-alone
treatment on a highly susceptible
cultivar in a severe disease year that
doesn't mean it has no effect
it simply means we're likely to find a
place for this uh in an ipm program as a
method that supplements
uh and improves the performance of other
measures uh in suppressing this
particular pathogen
and in fact that's that's exactly what
we were able to do
uh when we paired uv treatments with
post-resistance in 2021 on the hybrid
cultivar vignoles that's only moderately
susceptible to downy mildew
and it wasn't as severe a year
on vignoles uv applications reduced the
severity of downy mildew on the foliage
uh by about 75
so
uh while uv seems unlikely to perform
well as a standalone treatment against
downy mildew on a variety like
chardonnay
people put a lot of things in a spray
tank and on grapevines that do less than
provide a 75 improvement in the
performance of a control program so
these partially effective
forms of suppression
can still be very useful in the overall
context of an ipm program
here's one more example of a somewhat
unexpected effect
that's immediately relevant to to many
different crops
uh cooperative studies with john nyrop's
lab uh and other labs in norway
demonstrated that low level nighttime
doses of uv actually effectively destroy
uh the eggs of various mite species that
attack a broad range of important plants
both in controlled environments uh and
in field production systems
now this suppression has been very
consistent and the technique is now
widely used
in commercial strawberry production in
the netherlands where everything's grown
under glass
the primary effect of the uv
applications is on the immature stages
and in particular the egg stage
and that damage to the egg stage is
actually seen to some degree in the
future generations
we're just now beginning to understand
how uv treatments might affect other uh
insect and arthropod populations
there's
there are other research groups uh in
the u.s and elsewhere that are
independently
investigating the use of uvc against
botrytis ray mold of strawberry and
grape and they have reported some
modest degree of suppression
we haven't been able to reproduce those
results in our trials on either
strawberries or grapes it doesn't mean
the situation is hopeless it may just
indicate we have more to do with respect
to timing of treatments and dose and
interactions with environmental
favorability and cultivar susceptibility
just as we found uh with downy mildew on
grapevine
so
this graph
shows the first trials we completed
using weekly nighttime applications of
uv to suppress powdery mildew on
chardonnay grapevines in 2019
there are a lot of people now focused on
this specific area of research
it's really the combined solution of all
of these plant pathological
photobiological and engineering issues
that separates a usable
effective and safe apparatus from that
vineyard fryer that we uh we developed
in 1991 now i don't think
that uv is going to be you know the
solution to all of our problems
i do think we're at a stage where these
kinds of discoveries are occurring at a
greatly accelerated pace
just because of the number of people
working on it the number of trials going
on so things are happening at a pace
faster than once every 29 years
and as we gain more experience with
these trials we consistently improve the
performance of uv against all powdery
mildews
to the point where the efficacy often
equals the efficacy of a number of
fungicide standards so these are the
results from 2020 uh showing the best
performing of the uv treatments uh
against great pottery mildew on
chardonnay fruit
in trials in commercial chardonnay
vineyards
uh there's generally a
history of brutalism
constantly lowered pressure
we've been able to press power into the
trials uh price level on both foliage
weekly applications of
either 100
you could
half the dose traveling ice past
at our plant density we have about a
mile of
acre
so five miles per hour
an hour
and even on the shortest night here
around boston
it's the robots were
seven nights a
week robotic
single robot
in one week
so we're often asked well how long of a
dark period do you need after the uv
treatment and we generally recommend
about four hours however in those
instances where you're near the summer
solstice and the nights can be quite
short um
our results indicate you could probably
push that out to about two hours before
sunrise and still get most of the
efficacy of that uv treatment
in those situations we'd suggest
that you simply
for the last two hours of treatment
the dose be applied at a progressively
higher level to offset that decline in
efficacy
due to having less than four hours of
darkness remaining so this is a
challenge
but there's a practical solution
we're also asked uh questions about the
possible effects of uv on on fruit
appearance and quality in particular
with wine grapes
of course high rates of of uv can rust
at the fruit damage the vines
we proved that 1991
but we're using less than 10 of the uv
dose now that we used in 1991 and we've
really yet to see an effect on fruit
finish
so i want you to take a good look at
these uh these chardonnay grapes and try
to pick out the ones that are treated
with uv
uh and which ones are treated with a
fungicide standard
that's long enough
it's not obvious we found no differences
in berry size finish berry number
uh weight per cluster
between the uv treated and the fungicide
treated grapes
likewise there were no differences on
insoluble solid levels
um
among the uv treated and fungicide
treated grapes so it does appear we're
operating at or below the level
where we might damage the plants but at
a level that provides very good
suppression uh at least a powdery mildew
so this is a very busy graph
but it conveys a simple message we
monitored uh 20 different metabolic
responses of grapevines for two
consecutive seasons on vines that were
treated
with 200 joules per square meter and on
untreated vines now if you take any one
of those responses on the treated versus
the untreated and you divide it by the
value for uv
uvc by the value for the control
you get a ratio
if the ratio is equal to one
uh it's not significantly different from
one then the values are equal and
there's no treatment effect so this is a
way of comparing a lot of different
treatments that occur on multiple scales
on a single graph
and seeing if there's any real
many outstanding differences
so with respect to the broad range of
responses associated with uh
photosynthesis respiration electron
transport leaf thickness
chlorophyll content absorbance at eight
different wavelengths
none of these was significantly affected
even at the highest doses of uv
that we used
we're also asked um how how does uv
application affect microbial populations
on the surface of the grapevine leaves
and the fruit and so far these these
very preliminary studies and looking at
total culturable fungi and bacteria
it does appear
we are reducing the populations uh by
about 50 percent immediately after the
uv application
we also know that these populations
rebound in a matter of days
there's nothing in the data that we've
collected so far and it's it's it's
actually quite limited
but it doesn't suggest that there's any
residual or long-term effect of uv
applications on these surface
inhabitants and that's that's quite a
different situation from the use of a
fungicide where it might not only crash
the microbial population but it would
leave a residue
a longer lasting effect that might still
be detectable in some cases at harvest
well okay
what can we say with a fair degree of
certainty about the uses of uv on
grapevine well
first we're confident we can achieve
excellent suppression of powdery mildew
we've done this on uh several crops
other than grapevine
and the results from grapevine have been
uh quite consistent
the same goes for mites it doesn't seem
to matter what they lay their eggs on uh
we've been able to kill them with uv
next we've achieved good suppression of
sour rot which that's good news because
we don't have a lot of other things that
will effectively and reliably control
this disease complex
next there's partial suppression of
downy mildew where the degree of
suppression could be advantageously
combined uh with host resistance and
fungicide
as for botrytis
we haven't seen a measurable
suppression on either strawberry or
grape
but we haven't given up yet
now as for the effects on the vine
itself
it does appear that even at the highest
doses and most frequent applications
we're operating at a level below the
level of uv that would cause harmful
effects on either the foliage or the
fruit that's not entirely surprising
because that's exactly what we found in
strawberries and cucurbits and apples
and roses tomatoes hops basil and
rosemary
in grapes we've measured the effects on
leaf length and width shoot extension
net photosynthesis
stress metabolites berry size and so on
none of those responses indicated the
harmful effect of uv and there are
obviously a number of benefits uh with
respect to suppressing those things that
would certainly otherwise harm the vine
now
i started this story trying to describe
just how many people are
working together to to move this
research forward well here
here are those people
uh both uh our research team
uh and the project advisory group now in
in this photo
going from right
your left to right okay
is laura peterson uh probably known to
many of you
she's a former extension educator now
growing a lot of acres of vegetable
crops in the geneva area
eric seidman
near her
is a former director of the northeast
organic farmers association they both
advised the project in eric's case
despite the fact that he and i shared an
office together as graduate students at
the university of new hampshire he still
speaks to me
that's a rupally super parent standing
beside arne stensfont there are two
members of the research team from norway
next are mariana figuero and mark ray
two research team members from of all
places the light and health center at
mount sinai hospital in new york city
you can combine their names with light
and they'll fill up about the first
three pages of a google search so that
they do some fascinating work i'd
encourage you to look them up they work
on human health as well
beside me is oli mirna he's a project
advisor who is a strawberry grower in
norway he's a mechanical engineer and
he's an inventor and a member of the
project team i'm sorry project advisory
team
rebecca seidman
beside him is a professor of organic
agriculture again at the university of
new hampshire a member of the project
advisory team and married to eric
bob seem of course is my long time
colleague co-conspirator and supervisor
at cornell
in the bottom row is natalia perez
a professor at the university of florida
who's the project lead for on all things
having to do with strawberry
uh next to her is her former graduate
student rodrigo and norfrey he's now an
assistant professor at kansas state
university
lance kadel davidson is of course
a great geneticist at usda right here
cornell
and he's responsible for overseeing all
of the work on grapevine
below the cellular level
up is jan nairo who is our main contact
in working on the effects of uv with
arthropod pests
and then next would be walt mahaffey and
michelle moyer two great pathologists at
usda at corvallis and
washington state university at crosser
respectively and lastly the newest
member of the team is katie gold who's
joined the research team and brings to
the table an entirely new set of uh
skills extending far beyond visible
light into hyperspin into the
hyperspectral region
so
my role is really just is the the kind
of the spokesperson for the project
i consider my job to be to get you
interested in this work
uh keep you interested in this work at
least long enough that you'll ask me
some questions about it so we're gonna
stop here
i apologize for the technical
difficulties they are due to me
uh but i'm happy to answer any questions
from either the group here or the remote
uh location so thank you for your
attention
uh
it's great to be back
david
this is chris
i'm gonna read uh two questions from
chat and then you can take a couple from
the room uh if you want to stop sharing
that might help
um uh elizabeth buck asks uh when you
were talking about uh not using uv two
hours before dawn
um she was saying uh like actual sunrise
or more like uh civil civil twilight
um
we actually begin the applications at
civil twilight so you could probably
consider civil twilight to be the the
starting point for
um
when the the applications would be
ineffective
so you can use civil twilight that for
those of you don't know what civil
twilight is that's about 30 minutes
before sunrise
and
and then uh
great talk
was wondering what is the interaction of
uv and fungicide application do you
think uv application may facilitate the
uh
evolving of uh fungicide or antibiotic
resistant isolates
or shift the fungal population structure
it definitely has the potential to shift
the population structure uh but the
populations are shifting all the time
anyway so i don't know if the uv
applications cause a specific shift with
respect to resistance
uvc lamps have been used in medical
applications for about 75 years
mostly against bacterial pathogens
surface contaminants human pathogens
there are no known examples of
resistance to uv light
or
a direct link between the use of uv for
sterilization in something like
operating rooms
and the occurrence of antibiotic
resistant strains so
it's possible
there isn't any direct evidence to show
that it's been happening
so this this question has been raised
many times in human pathology
we're just we're way behind them in
plant pathology so i don't have a
definite answer to that all i can say is
point towards hospitals and say it's not
happening there
great
questions in the room i can't see the
room
in the back why do you need um the few
hours of darkness
after a treatment for it to be effective
okay the question was why is there
darkness required after the treatment in
order for it to be effective and the
reason is because of this photolyzed
uh blue light driven repair mechanism
you can kill them with daylight
applications but it takes a lot more uv
10 times the amount that it takes at
night because during daylight they can
fix the damage to the dna as fast as it
occurs
syria
first i want to let you know why i'm
sitting in the corner because the
review worked great for uh for another
in the lab but did not work in the field
uh
so
i'm being threatened here yes so when
you take the example of the beach
do you think if we increase the doses
for the graves in the vineyard we might
get better control for the dawn we use
that is that opposition i don't think
you really want to increase the dose a
lot beyond 200 joules on grapevine so
different crops will respond differently
to the same dose of uv
grapes can tolerate 200 joules per
square meter they can tolerate that dose
multiple times per week
tomatoes are damaged at 50 joules beets
can tolerate
400 500 600 joules
per square meter
you have to look at each crop
individually
so do i think that
if we increase the uv dose on grapevine
that we would get better control of
downey
possibly
but
killing the vine is not a good way to
control an obligate parasite so
we've done that experiment in 1991
yes
when you were testing to see if
you do be effective against downey in
the fields were you applying the uv
pre-symptomatically or once symptoms
that already shown up based on those
results in the lab where it was more
effective pre-infection or pre yeah when
the field you're doing both by default
you don't have a control over natural
infection periods and so yes you're
using it before infection and after
infection
and you don't really know with precision
which one's happening
we do know it didn't work very well
we proved that
katie um
so if i remember correctly one thing
that dave noted in the 2019 trials with
sauer was that he noted that there was
more botrytis
in the uv treatments and i wonder if
that's because botrytis and sauron
compete for the same niche like last
year in our trials we saw because sauron
was so severe we had very little
botrytis do you think that there's any
other um
patho systems where you might see that
sort of thing happening like you know
where you clear out something that is
targeted by uv but then you accidentally
like clear open a niche for something
else
so the question was in the initial
trials on the control of sauerat there
was a increase in the level of botrytis
do we think that by controlling one
disease
with uv we might open up an avenue for
an increased
uh severity of a second disease
so
in the 2019 trial there was a slight
elevation of botrytis in that trial
in 2021 there wasn't so
could it happen
yes the effect was rather mild uh we
could say it's significant or
non-significant depending on the
probability level we choose so it was a
difference
but it it wasn't reproduced
this is still a relatively new area of
research so we don't have other examples
of that
uh to go by
got it in several different pathos
systems we haven't seen that occur yet
maybe it hasn't happened yet
chris are there more questions from
ithaca yeah sorry uh in chat i i didn't
mean to interrupt uh robert richter um
have you measured tdn levels in
fermented wine i i have read that i
personally chris read that tdn causes a
petrol flavor in riesling
sounds delicious
and if they cut off our russian gas
perhaps we can
use that but
um we have not made wine out of these
grapes yet
that is going to come probably in the
next year or so so i don't have an
answer for that question
gillian asks has anyone tried this
experiment with a circadian clock mutant
of the pathogen
um
there have been a number of experiments
where people have messed up the
circadian clock of various fungi uh
using uh false dawn and other tricks
that you can do with light
uh with counter phasing uh
most of the work has been done in plant
systems not in fungal systems
that would be interesting gillian did
you wanna
okay
um marjorie
asks is it better for full foliage to be
blown around when applying uv in the
field in order to increase exposure
under the surface and then elizabeth
adds on to that is canopy structure a
limiting factor in large leaf cucurbits
in one
published paper
where someone has actually looked at
this experimentally
having fans on the array actually made
things worse
probably by dispersing the pathogen but
that's that's that might be a peculiar
system in for for a greenhouse
probably the easiest way to access
of otherwise shaded parts of the canopy
is not to move the canopy because as you
move the canopy you're simply
changing what's shaded
so
prop the best a way pro to probably
approach that is getting the most
reflectance angles that you can uh to
come out the canopy from several
different angles and that's what we do
with the front back reflectors and those
that entirely reflective surface on the
inside of that arch
so it's not something
that
we couldn't try
in the one case where it's been tried it
actually made things worse
and in the last question from chat uh
how long were the vines followed to
determine the effects of uv on the vines
over a season years
we've done this now for
multiple locations for three successive
years we're not looking at things like
return bloom
grapevines are treated pretty harshly by
the people that grow them you cut off a
lot of a grapevine
you remove
probably 20 percent or more of the
canopy as a management practice
during the summer so they experience a
lot of defoliation
simply from
the vineyard manager
all right any other questions one more
question from the room and then you can
stay but then we're going to cut this
off
one more question
and if not they want to leave all right
all right well let's thank david for a
great seminar
well done
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu